KNIGHT: And I'm ready.
FRIEDMAN: Okay.
Hope that this is working well.
And I guess this is where we can begin
the conversation.
This is a Twitter spaces.
On September 14th, 2022,
it is called
"Can Web3 Survive
Without Cognitive Modeling?"
And I know there's something they say
about headlines
that end in a question
mark, something like always
they're yes answers or no answers or...
In this conversation, we're going to be
talking about Web3
and about cognitive modeling.
FRIEDMAN: And it will be less than an hour long,
hopefully will serve
as a nice
introduction to those who have
little or some familiarity
with Web3
and cognitive
modeling alone or together.
But it's also meant to be kind
of a broad
ranging discussion,
and hopefully we'll have
some other voices
come up and add in some
thoughts and questions.
Let's start
with just a description of Web 3.
Surely elsewhere
you'll be able to find
audio and other kinds of content
describing Web3.
So I'll just describe
what's relevant about it as we
talk about cognitive modeling
Web3.
Web3 is an ongoing movements
that is applying blockchain
and other
distributed technologies
to a wide ranging areas.
And we can think of Web3
as creating critical infrastructure
either of the public goods type, or not
necessarily public goods
in a wide range of areas.
FRIEDMAN: So in finance,
there's decentralized finance or DEFI,
FRIEDMAN: and DEFI requires the engineering
of token schemes,
which is sometimes
called "token engineering" or "tokenomics,"
such that those token-based systems
are able to be designed
effectively and operate effectively.
And there's a lot of other
areas outside of the financial
that are important for Web3,
for example, community governance
and matter governance,
like what people may have heard
about daos
decentralized autonomous organizations,
as well as all other kinds
of organizations
and of particular interest for
our institute
and for many others
is decentralized science or design,
and in many ways deci will succeed
if it can have a balanced and coherence
approach
to tackle all the challenges that face
the research and education
stack ranging from the who,
what, why, where, when, etc..
Our question
that we'll return to is
how can any of these areas
finance, community
research, science and education?
How can any of these areas
be successfully navigated
or designed for
without taking agents into account?
So this is very related
to agent based modeling.
And we're going to explore how there are
several approaches
to modeling these complex systems.
FRIEDMAN: And we're going to suggest that
complementing
top down structural
FRIEDMAN: modeling of these systems,
there's a really important role
for Agent IC
or what we can consider cognitive
modeling of the actors
in these systems themselves.
And we believe that without this
kind of like a bottom up,
individual driven account
taking conceptually
into the design process,
but also more formally
into the specification and evaluation
of these critical infrastructure
or systems
that there are going to be
a lot of blind spots
and a lot of failure modes
that just simply will not be addressed
by the structural analysis alone.
FRIEDMAN: Bleu Want to
add on that
we can continue talking about this.
KNIGHT: Also, I can say a couple of things.
So I think
agent based
modeling is a super useful approach
when you are getting into systems
that are multi-agent,
that are maybe predictive
of any kind of outcome.
So like if this,
then that, like
how many agents does it take to defect
for a system to fail?
Like, you know, if if
everybody unloads their nifty
all at once, then the system collapses.
KNIGHT: So so it's these kinds of things.
And what is the cognitive
underpinnings?
KNIGHT: What are the cognitive
underpinnings of the decision
making in an agent?
Because everybody's
influenced by a variety of factors,
personal and environmental.
So agents can start off
with like more of a
of a different disposition,
like than others,
which is how we are
in the real world and
can have
different reactions
to environments with this.
KNIGHT: And I think that that's all I'll say
about that.
FRIEDMAN: Great point.
Agent based
KNIGHT: modeling is really helpful
for telling factual analysis
because we can ask, well, what?
What would be different
if we had this many
instead of that
many of this kind of entity,
or if they could do this
instead of that,
going back
to the critical infrastructure
and the need to design them
reliably
and also de-risk
against a variety of failure
modes, have three has some failure modes
and threat services
that are very similar
to what is seen in
Web two
and just other technological areas.
FRIEDMAN: And there's also some unique
and partially modeled scenarios
FRIEDMAN: in Web3
relating to blockchain
and distributed
technologies specifically.
And a lot of the complexity
has come
from the nested scales of decision
making and modeling
that come into play in Web3.
So just speaking coarsely,
there are decisions and discourse
at the level of layer
one chains themselves like blockchains
or among blockchains
as we're observing in this current day
around the Ethereum changes
that are happening known as the merge,
but even within a layer, one chain,
there are multiple tokens
and other kinds of entities
on that chain
and different communities
that might be using the same
or different tokens or their own tokens
and teams and projects
that might be on chain or off chain.
So there's a lot of interacting
FRIEDMAN: in nested layers of analysis.
So considering how different effects
greetings, yogurt, how different effects
of different actors,
partly
through that
kind of a complex
system is a key question.
And we can talk about a few difference
judgment, but I make you
if I get to speak, we can talk about
a few different modeling
paradigms and approaches
and talk about what is state of the art
and used wisely,
widely and wisely today,
and then how cognitive
modeling specifically
might be complementary
and empowering those methods.
FRIEDMAN: So just speaking broadly,
I'm going to mention smart
contract auditing
and then top down structural approaches.
And then lastly, bottom up
agent approaches,
which is the cognitive
modeling approach.
So first,
just speaking to smart
contract auditing,
smart contracts are familiar
in financial areas
and in kind of on chain
DEFI applications,
although smart contracts
also underlie technologies
like DAO
design
and citations,
identity, intellectual property,
all kinds of aspects of society
and culture
may be occurring through broadly
what are known as smart contracts.
FRIEDMAN: And the computational details
of smart contracts can be audited
along the lines
of security audits for other kinds
of computational programs.
For example,
a Hacker
Noon article describes
that smart contract auditing identifies
any errors in the code
and ensures that the code is safe
to use when transferring funds.
And so that kind of smart contract
auditing is able to assess
whether, for example,
a given reservoir of funds
can be extracted
by an unauthorized user.
FRIEDMAN: That is absolutely valuable.
And we're not suggesting
that cognitive modeling replaces that.
We have two modes
of systems modeling beyond simple,
smart contract auditing
that are relevant,
and that's the top down
structural modeling
and the bottom up
modeling, perhaps, Jakub,
you could describe
top down and bottom up approaches to
modeling here.
JAKUB: Yeah, sure.
By the way, I'm on my phone right now
because I
am just walking
in the middle of the city.
So if the background noise is too loud,
just let me know.
Yeah.
On the
on the top down versus
bottom up approach.
I think the main,
main, I guess
in classical cat kinds of modeling,
the one of the main approaches is to
identify the structure of the
of the system that's being studied.
JAKUB: In this case, it could be
a decentralized protocol that
enforces certain behaviors
by smart contracts.
And then this kind of
top down structural modeling is
amateur sweeps,
where we try to identify
all the different
all the different states
that the system can reach.
And but that doesn't
really tell us anything
about what
state this system will actually reach.
JAKUB: And how it performs
from the perspective of its users.
So the bottom up cognitive
suite,
but on the.
FRIEDMAN: Okay, yeah,
I'll give your audience a little bit.
JAKUB: About
more rigorous cognitive analysis
from the perspective of the
of the participants within that system.
So the idea behind active
blockchains is to kind of balance
these two approaches
and to take insights from
from both.
I hope that provides a brief overview.
FRIEDMAN: Yep. Thank you.
I'll just kind of summarize that
because there's
a little bit of cutting in and out,
but the top down
in the structural approach to modeling,
which is commonly used in
tokenomics suites like card code
that was mentioned by Jakub,
it describes system
states like the yield return percentage
on some kind of a smart contract
and other system parameters.
FRIEDMAN: And then
it specifies
the state spaces
which those parameters can exist in.
And these tools
also enable
FRIEDMAN: parameter sweeping
across those system parameters.
And that's like a macroeconomic analysis
that can be
said to be
taking like a population level
approach
to modeling the behaviors
of these complex systems.
So that would be equivalent
to like modeling a macroeconomic sector
with systems of equations
and then exploring how those equations
influence each other.
FRIEDMAN: And in contrast,
there is a bottom up agent approach
which entails a cognitive model
FRIEDMAN: of the agents,
because the cognitive model is
which we're using in the active
inference sense of the generative model
that provides that agent
with the ability
to engage in perception,
cognition and action,
where cognition is describing
various functionalities like memory,
preference and action
selection, anticipation and so on.
FRIEDMAN: So we've been thinking about
this angle
of cognitive modeling in Web3 a lot
because our project, Active
BLOCK Friends
is an open source package
that is explicitly addressing
and trying to enable this kind
of cognitive modeling in web3.
And we're going to have
a bunch of time to discuss
aspects of where cognitive modeling
could apply in Web3.
And I'm going to highlight
three areas,
but we'll discuss them one by one.
FRIEDMAN: And also,
FRIEDMAN: if anyone listening wants to join,
they can absolutely feel welcome
and there's going to be three areas
or points of contact to explore.
So this should be pretty fun and Bleu
and Yaacov
after each one of them,
like, Please
feel free to share
how you see it playing out or what
you think is useful about it.
FRIEDMAN: So here's reason one for why
we will argue that
Web3 needs cognitive model
is that we need to understand
the consequences
of single actions
taken by single actors.
There are also singular
events that happen at the system level
that we might want to model, like rare
or really important
cascade type events like a flipping,
and that might be able to be modeled
or detected or designed around
using top down structural approaches.
FRIEDMAN: Again, thinking about macroeconomics,
one could imagine
they have some dynamical equations
describing different currencies,
and then they could identify
like a change point
when one currency flipped another.
That's the flipping.
We're also interested in the potentially
cascading consequences
of single actions by single actors.
So this one specific transaction
that this one address sends to this one
smart contract is possibly able
to induce
widespread consequences
for the whole system
and that level of atomic granularity
in terms of which entity did
which affordances,
which action towards which entity
and then understanding the consequences
of that action.
FRIEDMAN: At that granularity,
it simply is inexpressible
FRIEDMAN: within the structural
or top down mode of modeling,
which really can be said to abstract
over individual entities and actions.
So we're not denying that the structure
or the top down can provide an immensely
course grained, useful representation
of systems
during design and implementation,
but also
we in this first point argue
that Web3 needs cognitive modeling
because we do want to model
and understand
the consequences of single actions
that single actors take
blue or.
KNIGHT: Gold walk up.
If we
have anything there,
I will defect and wait
until we talk about multi-agent systems.
I think. Yeah.
JAKUB: Yeah.
JAKUB: I think
I might add that
also there's also a lot of
interesting overlap with
the work on
computational psychiatry or
other
kind of psychology oriented
models in the sense that this
by analyzing,
by analyzing the cognitive states
of agents
and
things like how
well what are their levels of curiosity
within within, within a system, or
is it is a
is the distribution of beliefs
more skewed towards
higher levels of uncertainty or.
FRIEDMAN: Okay, I'll give you your all details
so it's not too good.
Yeah.
So yeah, but let me try to pick up
with what you mentioned
about computational literature, though.
So a top down structural analysis
of computational psychiatry
might be able to say
10% of such and such group
have this condition, and of them, then
1% go on to do this,
and 1% of that goes on to be this way.
FRIEDMAN: And so one could
develop estimates
like per
thousand people
FRIEDMAN: with this characteristic.
We can expect these outcomes
as a health care system
or as an educational system.
But again, the level of expressivity
or granularity
to describe measurements
coming from a given individual
like self-report
or measurements
made of their brain and their body,
these kinds of measurements
just don't have a place
in structural, top down modeling.
FRIEDMAN: So it may be absolutely useful
to take this macroeconomic
structural top down
perspective,
to have population level descriptors.
However,
the view
from the inside,
the bottom up in the agent perspective
and to incorporate the kinds of data
and information
which we have in the blockchain case,
like individual
addresses, making transactions,
we need to have agent level modeling
to be able to have that kind of a
personalized clinical relationship,
a personalized education relationship,
or making systems that account for what
individual actors
expect to prefer and can do,
rather than just designing systems
only at the level of system states
based parameters,
and then expecting that somehow,
whatever it is
that agents expect or prefer
can do,
FRIEDMAN: we'll simply work within that framework.
Okay.
So that was the first point
about why
Web3 needs cognitive modeling,
because again,
it's important to model
and understand
the consequences of single actions
that single actors take,
which might be extraordinarily rare
or improbable.
And so we won't be able to have useful
top down
modeling of those kinds of actions.
FRIEDMAN: Here's the second point.
We believe that Web3 needs
cognitive modeling
because we want to consider
the function of Web3 systems
that are not simply quantitative
or financial.
For example,
science, research,
education, governance,
all of these areas
are not strictly about number crunching.
And so in these settings,
knowledge and meaning,
which are based around context
and we could even say
that they're non-fungible
knowledge and
meaning making of epistemic entities
will not be engaged
with by top down
structure or
structural modeling
or smart contract auditing,
because quite literally
it is about the situated entity
and they're epistemic experience
like the kinds of observations
that they're making
and how that's updating
their generative model
FRIEDMAN: and then what that is
helping them to do.
So the way that
that would get shoehorned
into a structural model would be assume
that some percentage of individuals
are going to listen to this podcast
and then that makes some of them
more likely to engage in this action.
So that is again,
that view from the top,
just like we explored
in the computational psychiatry
case, that view from the top
or a probabilistic way
to talk about the actions of groups.
FRIEDMAN: And this is the complementary view,
which is the view from the bottom.
And this second point
is just to say that
FRIEDMAN: especially if we're going to step beyond
quantitative and financial analysis,
that these kinds of knowledge
and meeting
make meaning,
making behavior of entities are just
doubly inaccessible
unless we have cognitive modeler.
So to design appropriate systems for
science, education, governance,
we will need to have models
of what individuals observe,
believe, prefer and do, rather
than hoping that we can simply specify
the state space
that the system can exist in
and then let individuals
run within that framework.
KNIGHT: BLITZER I'll follow up on that.
I think that's like yes, for did decide,
but also systems
like regenerative
finance will require
novel methods of accounting.
And so this kind of cognitive
modeling will enable,
I think what Jakob was saying
earlier, that maybe Daniel
we haven't touched on yet,
but this parameter sweeping.
So so like when
when a person values something,
whether it's carbon credits or,
you know, epistemic knowledge, when
so when the value system differs
from dollars and cents, these kinds of
ultimate accounting systems
are enabled
or facilitated
by this kind of cognitive modeling.
KNIGHT: Like will
these value systems and structures
work for these people?
And,
you know,
multi-agent systems
can have variable value systems.
So I think that these parameters
will greatly help us to determine
what kind of alternative
accounting structures would.
FRIEDMAN: Yes, and there's
many ways, and it is by no means trivial
to incorporate these really rich
and expressive
things that we want to say
about such systems into the model.
For example,
even just in the example
that Bleu
brought up with regenerative finance
to describe how different individuals
are making different decisions
that might be a function of differences
in their capacities.
FRIEDMAN: So they're affordances
are capacities for action.
It might also reflect
different attention
or different beliefs
about the consequences
of different actions.
And so there are vast combinations
of cognitive models to explore.
And for that reason,
being able to do parameter
sweeps across them,
which is what card card
the package enables is really valuable.
And that's
why Active Conference
is implementing active
inference models in card code
because it provides a useful
and professional way
to do some of these functions
that are just not part
of cognitive models in a narrow sense,
like being able to do parameter sweeps,
being able
to specify the execution orders.
FRIEDMAN: But that's a bit
FRIEDMAN: more on the technical side of active
block runs, which
FRIEDMAN: definitely we encourage people
to learn more and get involved with and
help with.
I'll just go to this third.
Yes.
All so.
JAKUB: Okay, so
yeah, if I could just
quickly follow up on that.
On the notion of parameter sweeps,
I think they also serve
two kinds of functions.
On the one hand, it's for
predictive purposes.
So
designing models
and of different organizational systems
and running multiple simulations
to evaluate the different consequences
of that system.
But on the other hand, we can also serve
an explanatory purpose where by
we want
to evaluate
the state of an already existing system
given data on the blockchain.
JAKUB: So what active
what the formalism of active inference
allows us to do is to take
data from the blockchain
on the different actions
that different agents take or active
within the system.
Take, and then do a parameter
sweep over their beliefs to identify
which set of beliefs
make their actions base optimal
and once we identify
that set of beliefs,
we can do further analysis on what
that means from a cognitive sense.
JAKUB: In what
what would that mean in different,
different scenarios
and do this kind of more
this retrospective
analysis of the system.
And one more thing on the
on the voting mechanisms,
just to give an example, I think there's
an increasing
increasing
or it is increasingly mentioned that
quadratic voting is a more optimal,
optimal paradigm
for for voting
and governance in general.
JAKUB: But why why does it have
why is it quadratic?
Why isn't there an
exponent or fourth exponent?
And these kinds of questions,
I think, can be answered
through cognitive modeling,
where we can evaluate
the tradeoff
between a
higher mathematical complexity,
where the operation itself
at more cognitive constraints
and the actual results
when the agents act within
that voting system.
JAKUB: So
just want to give this example of how
it can be used in a purely non-monetary
governance type setting.
FRIEDMAN: Nice points.
You laid out
a lot of the kind of modeling pipeline,
which is that
the blockchains themselves
actually already contain
the exact kind of agent level
empirical data
that we want,
and it's even structured
in the way that we want to take it in,
which is like which entity,
which address did what
and then
what was the consequence of the action.
FRIEDMAN: So indeed that information
is already on chain
and summarized
in a way
that's amenable
to fitting cognitive parameters.
So the question of how to determine
which cognitive models are relevant
is it's indeed a challenge,
but at the same time
the data that is input
is of the right type
to fit various cognitive models
that could be useful.
For example,
some hidden state that describes
how somebody
how much attention
somebody is paying to a given
given governance system as overall
and then also being able to sub specify
at a given time
or changing through time.
FRIEDMAN: There are preferences
on a variety of topics
and that's exactly what allows
FRIEDMAN: the counterfactual analysis
or exploring like alternate futures,
because we could ask, well,
what if people were paying
more attention?
Is that an important area to go
or should it be
explored to modify
not the
attention being paid to this issue,
but rather how much they know about it?
FRIEDMAN: So nice point there.
So for financial
and for non financial systems
where entity level knowledge
and meaning making is relevant,
which it arguably always
is, that is an important
opening for cognitive modeling
and this view from the inside
to complement the top down
structural modeling.
Okay.
I'm going to just mention
the third of the points.
And then in the rest of the hour,
we can hear some different questions,
FRIEDMAN: different thoughts.
FRIEDMAN: So anyone who wants to speak,
thanks for requesting.
And the third point
is that we argue
that cognitive modeling can complement
traditional computational
security analysis.
So that looks like static
and dynamic analysis of smart contracts
and those kinds of analysis
can be complemented
by exploring in a testnet
or in a sandbox setting.
What happens
when that smart contract is deployed
in realistic settings,
which is to say, interacting
with other contracts
and interacting with individuals
who might differ
in their capacities,
preferences, expectations, and so on.
FRIEDMAN: So just to kind of give an example
that seems relevant here,
smart contract analysis could determine
if there was a contract
which was supposed
to hold funds securely
and only be able to take in one
or two kinds of tokens,
like a vending machine
you can put dollars in
and then soda comes out or you put soda
in and dollars comes out.
FRIEDMAN: So potentially
like a liquidity pool based swap.
Now
standalone
analysis of that smart contract
could absolutely tell you
whether it was possible for somebody
who shouldn't be able to access
those funds,
was able to access those funds.
There are also failure modes and risks
associated with that
smart contract in operation
that can't be said to be
within the smart contract.
FRIEDMAN: Rather, they're in the relationship
of that smart contract with others.
For example,
other contracts or exchanges
that are handling that
token might be engaged
in arbitrage relationships.
Once we think about social media
and information sharing that happens off
chain, there might even be narrative
or news based events
which make it
so that that smart contracts
ability to hold
the funds is great and enabling.
FRIEDMAN: However, still
in the realized application
of a contract
is functionally getting rugged as well.
And so these are all areas
that we want to explore more
with the active block firms package
as we kind of build
in these modules to consider it
and do case study analysis.
But that is just too close.
This section of the discussion as we now
open up to more broader discussion.
FRIEDMAN: And just to restate that,
three of the key areas, we think
cognitive modeling
can play a role in Web3
are first understanding the consequences
of single actions by single actors.
Second,
by expanding the scope of web3 systems
that we consider and designed
for to be systems
that aren't simply quantitative
and financial.
So considering
research, education, governance
and so on.
FRIEDMAN: And then lastly,
complementing
computational security analysis
with emulation and simulation
scenarios and counterfactuals of how
different aspects of cyber
physical systems
might play out
in specific testable settings.
So
thanks for making it along this far.
And now we can just
talk about whatever people would like to
go towards right.
KNIGHT: Thank you.
So
one of the things that's on my mind
is that
this is maybe
abstracting away
an important layer
that we're not really speaking about
whether we're doing
bottom up modeling or top down.
And that is, you know, that there are
miso or
middle level
structures that are relevant
to cognitive
modeling in terms of,
you know,
communities, cultures, organizations,
and they have influence
on the mental model that a person has
very explicitly by just talking about
the wallet.
KNIGHT: Or while
KNIGHT: it might belong to an individual
or it might belong to an entity,
but their behaviors will tend
to be different, might not even know
perhaps whether it is an individual
or some other sort of entity
that's behind a wallet.
But I think it gets more tricky
to think about,
well, you know, what is the environment
in which that entity that has the wallet
exists in like what culture,
what regulatory regime,
like what communities are they part of
and I don't necessarily know how
that should be done,
but it seems like
that is an important part of the context
that influences the model that any agent
has in choosing whatever transactions
KNIGHT: they make with their wallet.
And so you really have to
think about
how to address
that or
if you have thoughts
about how that should work, they have a.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you
for this comment about the MISO scale.
And I think there's
there's
just a few points to add on that.
Structural specifications of systems.
They identify really important system
level parameters,
but then it can often
be challenging
to add in other parameters
because the models are composable
only with macro aspects.
So it becomes harder to compose models
that are taking a purely top down
as well as a purely bottom up angle,
where cognitive modeling might help us
explore that.
FRIEDMAN: Middle is that
it makes a specific distinction
FRIEDMAN: between observed and unobserved
aspects of systems.
So hidden states are unobserved states.
The observed behavior in a blockchain
setting are like the transactions
that happen on chain.
And then
you're right
that there's so much context
that is unobserved
in that one
data artifact
that would be relevant to know about.
And so we can think about two cases
where this context is either
used or not.
FRIEDMAN: The first case
is where we actually have
no other context.
In that situation.
We can still do intentional stance
modeling towards
unknown types of actors.
Like We don't know what is behind this,
but we know that they engage
with this kind of a pattern.
And it's not enough
just to take a top down perspective
and say, Well,
this many people interacted
with this contract
or the average was two times per day
because that two times
per day
might be the average of a small fraction
that interact
a hundred times per day
and some that interact infrequently.
FRIEDMAN: So cognitive modeling
first would help us
take in intentional
in a strategic stance
in the absence of context.
And then
context as we add it in,
can become useful.
So we might know that multiple addresses
are under the control
of a given team or individual,
or we might have access to connecting
the social media profile of somebody
who puts it in their insights,
profile or page
that
could be composable at the agent level.
FRIEDMAN: And
I don't think that's an answer at all.
So open to whatever else people are
because
the miso is where the complexity is
and we would just expect and prefer
that the composability
of specifying
different kinds of entities
not just on chain entities
but also teams, organizations and so on,
that that will enable
these kinds of models
to do
exploration and parameter sweeps
in that exact space you described.
JAKUB: Thank you.
I would maybe also add to that
that as the toolbox itself
gets expanded and different
different computational models
are added, I think it's the
the case where we want to distinguish
between an actor that's actually
a single, single human versus
a team of people controlling.
And also multisig
should technically be reflected
in the underlying data to some
to some extent. So if
if for
instance, you want to analyze,
you want to use cognitive
modeling to analyze a certain DAO,
and you have a list
of all the different addresses
as you
perform this kind of multi agent model
or even try to fit the,
the belief states of each of the wallets
given given the prior data
it should become evident
that certain that certain wallets
perhaps are operating
at slightly different timescales or, or,
or maintain or
are updating their beliefs as a
in a different time scales
or in a slightly different way
than the other agents.
JAKUB: And then
and then we might also do
some cross correlation
between the beliefs states
and the individual actors
about whether you perhaps know
that they are individual actors
and the agents
that we are not sure whether they
represent a single
entity or a group of people.
So I think
that
a lot of it
might already implicitly be available
within within the current toolbox.
JAKUB: But as we add
more algorithms that do more efficient
computations and
different schemes of performing
belief updates and
belief search, I
that's a very interesting area
to explore as well.
FRIEDMAN: Thanks. Jakub! Brock, You want to add
anything?
BROCK: You know, I think the point here about,
you know, having some
verified data sources
and having these kinds of generalities
about how
one kind of data source
looks like for one kind of agent versus
another kind,
you know, more of an organization or
a syndicate
or some some other kind of non
singular individual is
correct.
And I think that this idea of
the massive scale being
missed, generally speaking, and modeling
is also correct.
BROCK: But and I think that
cognitive modeling in general affords
partially, I guess, a solution to
really this.
MEADOWS
Both of these problems
are really related to like the.
FRIEDMAN: Oracle problem.
BROCK: Of just
where does data come
and the trust
and all this sort of stuff.
BROCK: Because even if you get this culture
data, it's like,
you know, what's what's in the water,
what's in the food,
BROCK: what's this business doing with,
you know,
what are the externalities
of this process or whether,
you know,
there's a lot of still unknown data.
And the only way
that we currently have to kind of
model that effectively
is with essentially a cognitive
sort of model that, like you mentioned,
Daniel has this distinction between
observed and unobserved
or hidden states and,
you know, known
all states to the system. And so
it's never a guess to frame it.
It's it's like security
is this cat and mouse game really.
We're in this
now in this cognitive
and security cat and mouse game.
And we're just going to go further
into that.
But, you know, as a large corporation
or whatever,
some some syndicate or whatever,
trying to maybe obscure their,
you know, behavior on chain like
so that they're harder
to predict for some reason.
BROCK: Probably things like that, will
they already occur
in the political context today?
I'm sure that it will continue
and decentralize in that fashion.
And so it will just be
a baseline.
This will just be table stakes
to do cognitive modeling,
to have any kind of
on something like prediction or
discern ability of of these
kinds of systems.
FRIEDMAN: Nice. Very
interesting.
So in the last
10 minutes, we can have any speakers
join or people can ask questions.
This is happening during the ongoing
get coined funding round.
You are 15
and we have a grant in for this project
which is supportable
as well as many other awesome
public goods
and project projects
that people can check out.
FRIEDMAN: And
on the grant page
you'll see some recent discussions
we've had with.
KNIGHT: Cape Cod.
FRIEDMAN: Community
and with the Smart Contract
Research Forum,
where we talked about a few different
ongoing steps.
The current
status of the package
is that it's it's available.
It's an open source package and it is
framed as notebooks
primarily made by Yucca
that are like the perception, cognition
and action
of an entity in an abstract grid space,
which sounds and basically is general
and abstract.
FRIEDMAN: So some of
our next steps
are to bring that machinery
and that approach
to take in the kinds of empirical data
that are relevant
for blockchain systems.
So that's one key area as well,
as well as improving the functionality
of the package
through various means,
like improved ability to visualize
outcomes of models, to specify models
and sweep across them,
to have documentation
and other integrations
that will just make it a better package
and more useful.
FRIEDMAN: I guess in the last term
there's a few other ways to go,
but I'll pause
if anyone has any thoughts or questions.
The point I wanted to add in that again,
anyone can feel free to add is that
using active
inference as a scale
free or scale friendly
framework, as we sometimes say,
an advantage of it
is that we can talk about perception,
cognition and action
for different entities.
FRIEDMAN: This is not creating a little brain
for individuals, only people.
This is about being able
to look at how decisions are enacted
in different kinds of organizations.
And those organizations
could be
cellular biological organizations
like humans,
or it could be organizations
that you suspect
something complex is happening within,
but you're only seeing
the tip of the iceberg on chain.
FRIEDMAN: Or it could be organizations
that are entirely on chain.
And so that's one of the reasons
why it's important
to have a really flexible
modeling framework
like active inference
for cognitive systems,
because it's not bound
to, for example, only human emotions
and sensory processing.
It enables us to describe a wide variety
of systems in a cognitive fashion,
which is what we've explored
in our iOS work
Active Entity Ontology for Science.
FRIEDMAN: So that is where we see
active inference as a leading
cognitive modeling framework
and natural fit
FRIEDMAN: for this cyber physical space.
And then the other
pillar of the active blocker
and project
other than active inference is CAD CAD,
which was mentioned
earlier, and CAD CAD has been used in
a wide
range of token
modeling and engineering settings.
You can see actually
there is theorem validator models
which have been publicly available
for several years.
FRIEDMAN: I don't know the exact date,
but the work on CAD card modeling
of the proof of stake transition
has been in the works
for a really long time
and that kind of gives
a taste of
from the outside speaking virtually
of what it looks like to use
formal system models
over long timescales
to strategize and de-risk
really complex decisions
that groups and individuals make.
FRIEDMAN: And that is still
at the structural level.
So it's
one thing to be able
to scan across different validator
reward systems or percentages
and ask what would happen
if a certain parameter is set
to three or two or one?
Again, it's quite a different thing
to ask
how entities with different attentions
and preferences
will make certain decisions.
And so it'd be like the equivalent
of a macroeconomic change being induced.
FRIEDMAN: Like we raised the interest rate by 1%
are macroeconomic
curve intersection models
so that that should increase
FRIEDMAN: consumer spending by this much.
But that consumer spending,
even if it is an accurate prediction
from the structural modeling,
is enacted by individuals
making decisions
in response
to those common system parameters.
So that highlights
that the objective perspective
is complementary
to the systems
and the structural description.
FRIEDMAN: But we really think that it's going
to bring a level of depth
and also new challenges
because the deep space
of all cognitive parameters
and how they interact is truly vast.
So it will not be necessarily
the shortest or simplest road, but
we think it's going to be
one of the most meaningful
because it's going to
bring new function to
different
web3 ecosystems and subsystems
that otherwise
would have totally
incommensurate models.
FRIEDMAN: The defi models are not going to apply
that to our decision making
and those are not going
to apply to science and how that works
and having some kind
of an interoperable layer
for what entities are doing,
what is going to be
enabling really rich
modeling of web3 ecosystems now?
Can web3 survive
without cognitive modeling?
I don't know.
FRIEDMAN: We could vote,
but we we provocatively raised
the question.
I think
FRIEDMAN: Jakub and Brock and others
in some meetings with this framing,
because we do want to suggest
or at least raise this notion
that no amount of
top level systems engineering,
unless it's complemented by a bottom up
perspective on
what are the capacities,
attention, preferences
and so on of entities in this world,
the embodied natural ones
as well as like computational artifacts,
you know,
a runaway
decision making
AI with a trading balance,
all these kinds of systems
that we have to model,
including systems
that we don't even know
what type they are necessarily.
FRIEDMAN: We need
interoperable and expressive ways
to describe those systems.
So that's why we think that
web3 with cognitive modeling can survive
and without we just don't know.
KNIGHT: I have another question.
I think it relates
fundamentally to potential biases
in a model given data availability.
So
it's very clear always
what data is available,
like what transactions are on chain
or what prices are paid
in market for securities or commodity
or what have you.
But there is actually a lot that occurs
in society, which is not necessarily
a market type activity
with with hard data associated with it.
KNIGHT: And how does
the cognitive model account for the fact
that that many things are missed
and that we simply overlook
many aspects of things
that, for instance, might be called
the gift economy,
where people just informally do things
for each other.
And it's not really recorded anywhere.
I mean,
it is truly part
of the representation
of our individual cognitive models
for how we exist in the world.
KNIGHT: But
where is this going to make it
into any model that we try to do?
FRIEDMAN: It's a great question and it's a thread
I hope
we keep alive
even beyond this space
ending in a few minutes.
So no answer will do it justice.
But I'll give some thoughts.
One is the difference
between observables
in our model empirical data
that we're reading in and on observables
which are considered factors
but not necessarily ones
where we have data points
either
because we just haven't
added those data points in,
or maybe they don't even exist
in principle.
FRIEDMAN: So various
kinds of features can be observed
and various can't be.
So it's important to have a framework
that deals with those.
And then the second point
is that
it may be possible
for some kind of like out in the open
models
to use some kinds of
totally out in the open data.
But then let's just say that
within the context
of a given community of care,
people consented to
having their information
digested or summarized
and used to augment
a community specific model.
FRIEDMAN: So the provenance and the
use of that data
that would be potentially
FRIEDMAN: speaking to these more authentic
in organic social interactions,
those kinds of data could be grafted
or fuzed out with more open source
templates dealing with open data.
So there'd
be a lot of opportunity
for model templates
and some pre computed public goods
type data sets
to then be enriched on the edges
by different communities
that we're going to be
bringing in specific data types.
FRIEDMAN: And the
the path has been
in a way placed forward by card CAD
where the package is open source
and many of their models
are open source.
Yet
they're also able to engage with clients
in a consulting capacity using models
that are not fully open
source probably,
or data sets
that aren't fully available.
So it's one reason why we are
strongly open source with the package,
while also recognizing
that a lot of the last mile
use cases might bring in data
that isn't strictly open source
in the same way
that this code should be.
FRIEDMAN: Okay.
FRIEDMAN: Well, thanks for listening, everyone.
Please head over to,
I guess, our Twitter profile
to learn more about our ongoing get
going ramp.